after season seven staggering finale if
you as were left with questions I'd
never even anticipated from ice dragons
the cleganebowl and the fate of some of
our favorite characters he has a spoiler
filled look at all the questions Game of
Thrones needs to answer in its final
season ever since they first hatch
Daenerys history dragons have been an
integral part of the show
however in Game of Thrones most recent
season one of the Narrows says dragons
for Syrian was felled by the night's
king and fell under his thrall so what
does this undead dragon mean for
Westeros in the next season of so many
theories floating around it could be
hard to keep track but fans can expect a
dragon showdown at the very least season
sevens finale confirmed the long-held
fan theory that will seriously affect
the final season John is not Ned Stark's
bastard son but is instead a Targaryen
and the rightful heir to the Iron Throne
that revelation means that John and
Daenerys in for a nasty surprise since
they spend the season 7 finale becoming
very intimate considering that John has
promised to help Daenerys secure the
throne to herself things may get even
more awkward when she realizes her new
lover isn't just the biggest rival he's
also her nephew so far several names and
I as infamous revenge list have been
killed by other people and she's
personally taken down a few herself I
want you to know that the last thing
you're ever going to see is a stark
smiling down at you as you die however
there are still several huge names on
her less that haven't yet been taken
down though she thinks a hound is dead
he's actually still alive like why is
the executioner who killed her father as
well as big birds like the mountain
Melisandre and Cersei Lannister are
still on the loose for a year to hunt
down but will she be the one to end
their lives Cersei Lannister has always
been one of the show's most despicable
and complicated characters and currently
she holds the Iron Throne in the last
season she dropped a big
pregnancy-related bombshell we will help
stop this so as to the question of
whether says he truly is pregnant Jeremy
protists were the director of the season
7 finale chimed in to say that he
believes she wasn't lying but if she's
timed the truth it could hint at her
final fate thanks
a handy prophecy well the King and I
have children the king will have 20
children
you have three of course Circe already
had three children but in the books the
prophecy includes another warning that
Circe will be vanquished by her valonqar
or little brother though Circe has
always assumed this means Tyrion Jaime
is just a few minutes younger than
shares many fans believe that if she
really is pregnant with his child the
pregnancy could cost Cersei her life
Melisandre the red woman has been an
increasingly mysterious character on a
show filled with mysterious characters
even so she's done her part when needed
like when she raised Jon Snow from the
dead in season six in season seven
during a meeting with Varys the two
agreed that Melisandre should head to
volantis
I will return their Spyder one last time
milady
I have to die in this strange country
just thank you although that
conversation is riddled with clues for
superfans it's hard to decipher what
role Melisandre will play in the show's
final season Jaime Lannister might have
become a fan favorite over the course of
the show's run but he's still a morally
ambiguous character however through his
journey with Brienne Jaime seems to have
turned several corners he even swore to
fight against the White Walkers rather
than assist Cersei in her attempt to
shore power still at Jamie's always been
loyal to his sister when push comes to
shove so the question remains will he
put aside petty squabbles in the face of
the Whitewater invasion or will he stay
a Lannister through and through either
way he'll have a debt to pay and of
course you have also heard the phrase
Lannister always pays his debts one of
the most anticipated show downs and the
entirety of Game of Thrones is referred
to as per game ball which would see that
the game brothers pitted against each
other
the mountain has become a brainless mute
slave of Cersei and the Hound has gone
through his own trials that left him
eager for revenge simply puts there's
not much standing in the way of these
two fierce warriors chucking it out when
it's who were united at the end of
season 7 the hounds seemed to promise
that the game ball was on the horizon
doesn't matter that's not how it ends
for you brother you know is coming for
you you've always known
it's still unclear what role Bram will
play in the final season but naturally
fans of plenty of ideas
fans of theorized that bran exists in
every moment of time simultaneously or
even that bran himself could actually be
the mysterious and powerful night's king
it's also possible that Brown was the
catalyst for the mad Kings descent into
insanity no matter what the answer is
it's clear that brands rolled as a
three-eyed Raven will have a huge impact
on the final Caesar some of the most
meaningful moments on Game of Thrones of
command beloved characters reunite after
being separated for long periods and
season 7 looks to be full of these
moments one hotly awaited reunion is
between John and aya stark two Starks
who have always been extremely close and
fans are also curious to see if ire and
the Hound reconnect after his supposed
death
likewise who wouldn't want to see sons
are in Tyrion reunite after their forced
marriage ended up with some unexpectedly
sweet moments as the cast has dwindled
these longer weighted reunions are sure
to be some of the most emotional moments
in the series check out some of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]